Hi I'm Mine Cetinkaya-Rundel. I'm a
professor at Duke University
and a developer educator at Posit.
This year at posit:conf I'm
teaching a one-day teaching
data science master class.
I've been teaching data science
with R for over a decade.
And I can't wait
to share everything
I've learned over this time
about successful data science
pedagogy, teaching
with authentic tools,
and doing so effectively
and efficiently.
Here are the top
three reasons why
you should take this workshop.
First reason is keeping up
with the evolving data science
ecosystem is not trivial.
Keeping up with it and deciding
whether it's the right time
to update your
curriculum to incorporate
new tools or new features
of existing tools, new data
sources or new
workflows, and doing
so while concurrently
teaching can be overwhelming.
This workshop is
designed to share
with you what's new in
the land of teaching data
science with R and
to distill for you how
you can implement these
updates in your curricula.
Second, successful
teaching doesn't
end with successful
curriculum design.
The computational infrastructure
you use for your teaching
is an equally important part
of a successful data science
course, particularly if
your definition of success
takes into consideration
the experience
and enjoyment of your students
as well as of yourself.
In this workshop, we'll
tell quite a bit about how
to set up computational teaching
environments with Posit Cloud
as well as other
server-based tools.
How to use Git and GitHub for
version control collaboration
and as your course
management system
and how to teach reproducible
authoring with Quarto
as well as how to use
it to build your course
materials and sites.
And third, this workshop will
supercharge your learning
and teaching prep.
In one day of the
workshop, you will pick up
a wealth of information
and tips that
can save you weeks and months
of trial and error on your own.
Additionally, you'll meet a
community of like-minded data
science educators
with whom you can stay
in touch beyond the conference.
One final comment is that this
year, the teaching data science
workshop is offered as a
one-day workshop, which
means you can focus
on your teaching
on one of the workshop days and
spend the other day learning
something you've been hoping
to make time for all year.
Go to posit.co/conference to
register for this workshop,
as well as to find out about
all of the other fantastic
workshops we're offering
at posit::conf this year.
Looking forward to seeing
you in Chicago in September.